this week on brian ross investigates the
spies among us
three american traders the fbi's robert
hansen and the cia's aldrich ames and
edward lee howard are in prison for life
after being caught spying for russia but
tonight new allegations from former
c.i.a officer robert bear that there was
a fourth man working for russia who so
far has not been caught it was a matter
of deduction that they came up with this
guy's name
the cia is not talking but baer says
there's an active investigation of a now
retired top cia official paul redman
there's only one law
is always going to be spies
redmond strongly deny he's ever been a
spy for russia former colleagues back
him up
is paul redmond the fourth man no
absolutely not there's no evidence of
that whatsoever but the evidence is
overwhelming that moscow has had a
steady stream of top security secrets
from american spies leading to the
deaths of dozens of russians who were
working for the u.s so how do you put a
dollar value on that you know all these
lives that were lost i don't think you
can
plus this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin tonight with a real
life spy thriller amid concerns there's
been a russian mall inside the c.i.a or
the fbi who is yet to be caught the
so-called fourth man rhonda
that's right brian three men are behind
bars for working for the russians the
fbi's robert hansen and the cia's
aldrich ames and edward lee howard but
tonight you're going to hear about a
growing consensus that there was a
fourth man or woman who has provided
russia with some of america's most
closely held national security secrets
and we're joined now by robert baer a
former cia intelligence officer and the
author of the new book the fourth man mr
bear a legendary cia spy whose exploits
have been recorded in books and in the
film for instance sirianae where george
clooney plays bob bear bob a former
colleague of mine thank you so much for
being here in your book you document the
investigation into trying to find the
fourth man and you actually suggest
there is one prime suspect who came
under investigation what made him a
suspect in this case
according to the investigators and i
only use first-hand sources from this
book only first-hand sources
um
he fit a profile of compromises to
moscow
that ames couldn't account for and
hanson couldn't account for
uh they decided he was somebody who had
been assigned to langley for 10 years
starting on russia desk
and then moving over to
counterintelligence it was a matter of
deduction that they came up with this
guy's name
there's only one law
there's always going to be spies
this is the man identified in the book
as under suspicion paul redmond a now
retired cia senior official who was
actually credited with tracking down all
rich ames the russian spy inside the
c.i.a
ames would not have been caught without
paul redmond and as far as i'm concerned
paul redmond was the individual who was
chiefly responsible at an intelligence
community seminar after ames was caught
redmond even suggested there might be a
fourth man my only point here is i hope
that this will not be just viewed as a
quick fix and then we'll go on to other
things this case
all sorts of weaknesses clearly in the
bureau and elsewhere in our government
and certainly deserves a very close look
an investigation to see really what's
wrong so we can take sensible steps the
mall was the person looking for the mall
and he took credit for finding aldra
james tracking him down
he tracked down alder james nicholson
uh he also found out that there was an
fbi agent who turned out to be bob
hansen
and he's a legend at the cia
so why would he be a mole if he's doing
all this work to find russian spies
inside american intelligence
well i never said he's mole i just said
the russians as they described it it's
called the queen's sacrifice is you give
up
lesser moles
to protect your most important one
so like a chessboard move now he
actually talked to you i assume he
denied it
oh he absolutely denied it he said
listen we're
friendly and he invited me to come stay
with him he says
bobby you know i don't know why the fbi
has been after me for 25 years
i don't know what they think they have
i have no opinion about this internal
cia investigation
did you come away from that bob thinking
it couldn't be him
look
intuition
tells me it's not him
um
the fbi told me i only have a quarter of
the evidence against him
i haven't seen the original evidence and
if i were on a jury
i wouldn't convict
as best you know there is still an
active investigation into this fourth
man into this individual
i know there's an investigation because
the fbi is going around knocking on the
doors of my sources as of a month ago
in a very friendly way i don't think
it's a leak investigation saying
what did we miss here how can you help
us uh and the rest of it
and you know if you know this has been
this is a very active investigation and
it's not
because the fbi doesn't know what it's
doing it's just they cannot get a
smoking gun on
the guy they're after or somebody else
you also make the point in your book
that this fourth man whoever it is
really blinded uh the cia in american
intelligence into what was happening in
russia at a pivotal point in time
by 1998 the cia did not have a single
source in moscow
neither did the state department a
reliable source because the fourth man
betrayed them all to the kgb
i checked this every way to sunday
with clinton's national security council
staff the national intelligence officer
even the ambassador told me
look by 1988 1999 i got better
information from moscow taxi drivers
than i did the cia he's on the record
with that
and so given that the united states was
blinded as to the ambitions of vladimir
putin
putin came to power thanks to a very
quiet
statist kgb coup d'etat and we missed it
in the 90s because all of our kgb assets
agents had all been compromised and so
in effect putin was a slow rolling pearl
harbor
and so the whoever this fourth man is
along with aldra james and bob hanson
did incredible damage to the united
states
incredible damage if you draw a direct
connection between our ignorance of what
putin was up to who he was and the war
in ukraine we are closer to world war
three than we've ever been
and in a way this came as a huge
surprise to us
you submitted your manuscript for this
book to the cia uh did they uh want you
to not report certain things what do
they want you to take out
they took out all sorts of stuff like um
there was there was a spy in mi6 that
redmond found
and a guy named spedding who had missed
they did that details about that thing
smalling here i sent the manuscript both
to the fbi and the cia said look this is
a current investigation i know it no
matter what you say
if this impedes your investigation i
won't publish
uh no one wanted to take that on
i made the cia changes it was submitted
there are no sources and methods in this
book compromise
it's based on reinterpretation of public
information
in a couple small additions here and
there
so how was this book received by the
seventh floor as they call it the
headquarters floor well let's put it
this way i've been cancelled
there's no surprise is it brian not at
all not at all robert bear former cia
spy now great author thank you so much
for being with us here tonight
thanks
paul redmond declined to appear on our
program tonight but in a statement to us
he said robert bear's book is hogwash
filled with mistakes and misinformation
i have never ever been a russian spy
rhonda and we also heard from one of
redmond's longtime colleagues who said
he wanted to come on tonight and defend
the retired cia senior official
and we're joined now by david major who
for more than two decades worked foreign
counterintelligence at the fbi david is
a legendary figure in the american
intelligence community mr major thank
you so much for being with here tonight
thank you for your kind comments that's
true let me start by asking you is paul
redman the fourth man no
absolutely not there's no evidence of
that whatsoever first of all there is
evidence that there's something else we
don't even know it's a man we know that
we know that's for sure that if you look
at the cases during that time i worked
all that period i know all those players
i worked all those cases i was
intimately involved in it so i really
know this and i teach this does it make
sense that he can be a suspect
absolutely but is there evidence that
he's a spy none whatsoever and and
saying someone in our business is a
supply is a really really important
thing not to do if there's no evidence
right in bob bear's book he describes a
meeting at the cia where they
essentially are going through the matrix
of who it must be narrowing it down to
it looks like paul redmond and he
stormed out of the room
well that would be paul redman's
personality to be honest with you that
he was storm out of the room but not
because i think he was a spy that that
first of all that doesn't prove he's a
spy the fact that he was so what are you
guys talking about i mean i've been here
you know i spent my whole life to do
this and now you're saying it's me and
i'm in the room with you and i can see
why i would storm out of the room but
that doesn't prove he's a spy that's
simply how he emotionally responded to
someone making that acquisition
accusation remember this guy spent his
entire life in counterintelligence
looking for the spy and so forth to say
he is and then you know that would be a
pretty serious thing for him
and so the fact that he storms out
doesn't prove anything
how hurtful has this been to uh paul
redmond to have this raised now in this
new book
i think very harmful because in this
business our trust
uh is very important
in fact when you work in the business
and you know these people you have to
trust each other and carl was one of
those people that you trusted he's an
interesting personality you know he's
he's very volatile very strong opinion
that doesn't make him a spy it simply
makes him a strong personality which i
think you need in this business
in his statement to us he uh denied it
very strongly have you asked him
directly paul were you a russian spy yes
and
no didn't found it all not even close
but bottom line mr major you would say
there are some events that are not
explained by the
treachery of aldridge james or robert
hanson or the fbi there's somebody else
out there you think who has been spying
for russia inside the fbi or the cia
yes and do i believe there's somebody
else absolutely do i believe it's a man
i don't know it's a man it could be a
woman i said could be multiple people
do you think we'll ever know who this
fourth man or this fourth woman is
if we live long enough one of the things
i love about living is that if you live
long enough you'll probably always find
it right the rest of the story because
eventually it comes out somehow
someplace sometime somebody who knows
the answer will come out
now it may not be a year my lifetime but
i believe we will find out but i don't
believe we'll find out that it's paul
redmond
david major thank you so much for being
with us here tonight
my pleasure
when we come back what makes an american
intelligence officer turn on his country
a new look at the former fbi agent who
wanted to be like james bond
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network